oh
[Musique]
aucune règle
la publics appliquent pour les chick là
plus personne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est pas moi aller là bas
tu sais rien des quartiers nord
c'est qu'on sert à rien on sert plus à
rien
[Musique]
les habitants des quartiers ils ont même
eu l'espoir qu'on vienne les aider c'est
fini
qui penserait pas trop longtemps des
signes après quoi ce serait contraire
là on a envie de [ __ ] le réseau nous
faut une bonne vraie info la chine qui
3,5 kg je trouvais les ans c'est
possible
cette gamme est enregistrée fait comment
voyez vous c'est pas faux pas ce soir
pourquoi je devrais risquer ma carrière
parce nous donne les moyens de travail
il faut arrêter avec les suites et tout
le monde s'en branle le préfet le
premier juste airlines du journal pour
faire le monde
tu veux devenir officier cette opération
devant cette accusation raquette et
trafic de drogue en bande organisée
pasqua
ça fait 20 ans que je fais ce métier moi
je crois tu sais tu n'es tu sais rien tu
sais rien des quartiers nord on a failli
crever là bas
[Musique]
toi tu rentres chez toi tu risques que
rien
tu as ma parole
tu fais ce métier moi je le fais je
comprends pas pourquoi je comprends pas
comment d'en arriver là en fait
[Musique]